- All right, so it's time
for a New York version
of a game we like to
call "Throw Me a Line".
♪ Throw me a line ♪
(Kelly laughs)
- Seth has graciously agreed to host,
which, 'cause you're used to it.
- Yep!
- Which means we need another player,
so please welcome a Grammy
winning singer-songwriter
and real Housewife of
Atlanta, Kandi Burruss.
(audience cheering)
(jazzy music)
- [Kelly] Game time!
Game time! I don't even want a hug yet.
(laughs)
- Game time.
Um, I love your outfit, we're
gonna talk about that later.
Thank you for being here, Kandi.
- [Seth] Did not get a
comment on my outfit.
- [Kandi] Well thanks
for having me, Kelly.
(laughter)
- It's like you and Blake
shop at the same place.
(laughter)
- You know what? Save it Adam Levine!
- Uh, no, so I don't know the lyrics
to like any songs, like, for not-
- [Kandi] I don't, either!
- [Kelly] Not even mine,
I'm even worse at mine.
- I'm horrible at song lyrics.
- [Kelly] Okay, so don't worry.
- This is-
- And I'm a songwriter,
but I'm not good at it.
- [Kelly] Me, too, but even playing field.
I'm horrible at it.
- [Kandi] Okay, good.
- But will you explain
how this game works?
- [Seth] I would love to
explain how it works, guys.
(Kelly laughs)
I'll read a line from a song
that has some sort of
connection to New York.
First person to buzz in on
your buzzers right there,
and sing the title of the song,
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Seth] gets the point.
(audience cheers)
- [Seth] So if I say, if I say-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- (Seth) I once was
lost, but now I'm found,
(buzzer)
you buzz in and sing.
♪ Amazing Grace ♪
Well, I want that one! I want that one!
(audience cheers)
(Kandi laughs)
- [Seth] We got it!
- [Kelly] Was that the easiest one?
Oh, crap! Okay.
- [Seth] That was the easiest one.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay, okay.
- [Kandi] Okay.
- All right, guys, this is important, too.
Kelly is playing for
the men in the audience.
- Ay!
- And Kandi is playing for the women.
(audience cheers)
And the winner gets a
prize for their group.
So let us begin.
Are we ready?
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- First lyric, "hanging out
the passenger side of my-"
(buzzer)
- [Kelly] Ohh, who did it first?
♪ Of my best friend's ride ♪
- No wait, it's me, it's me!
- Uh-uh!
How are you first?
♪ Of my best friend's ride ♪
- [Seth] All right, but
what's the name of the song?
- [Kelly] Scrubs.
♪ I don't want no scrubs ♪
- [Seth] All right.
♪ A scrub is a guy that
can't get no love from me ♪
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- [Kandi] She beat me on my own song!
- [Seth] This is very-
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kandi] That is crazy!
- [Seth] This is deeply,
this is deeply hard for Kandi
because Kandi, tell them
why that's a burn on you.
- Because I wrote those lyrics!
(laughter)
(audience cheers)
♪ Hanging out the passenger side ♪
♪ Of his best friend's ride ♪
- You know what?
♪ Trying to holler at me ♪
- You did a good job!
- I can sing the whole verse to that!
- [Kelly] Ay, you know what? You did...
I can sing the whole song.
Ma'am you did a good job,
(buzzer)
but I hit it first, so.
(audience laughs)
- Dang, I got to be faster.
- [Kelly] You got to be quick.
- I grew up in an era where
women would often sing
that entire song to me
is the reason for why...
(laughter)
- And you still got the shirt!
(Seth laughs)
- I still got the shirt!
- You write an amazing song when only
like, three words are
spoken and I can buzz in.
- [Seth] All right, here we go.
Ready?
- Well done!
- Oh my gosh!
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Seth] All right, next lyric.
"And the world's gonna know your name.
What's your name, man?"
- And the world's gonna know your name.
- [Seth] And the world's
gonna know your name.
What's your name, man?
(audience groans)
It is New York. It
takes place on Broadway.
♪ And a New York ♪
- No, not that one.
- [Seth] You know?
- [Seth] It's a Broadway show,
and the world's going to know your name.
♪ New York, New York ♪
- [Seth] Nope.
- No?
- And the world's gonna know your name.
Say it again.
- [Seth] What's your name, man?
Your name is Alexander Hamilton.
(audience groans)
(buzzer)
- [Kelly] Oh my!
Okay, wait. Okay, wait.
(audience boos)
- That is bad!
- What do you mean wait?
- Okay, wait.
- Wait what, wait for you to see it?
- Because there are a lot of lyrics in all
of those songs, okay?
- [Kandi] Ohh!
- Hey, this is your show, it's your game!
(laughter)
- Exactly!
- [Seth] I'm just here!
- I've seen that twice.
Like, why didn't I know that?
- All right. Ready, guys?
- I honestly was thinking like pop songs.
- I don't want to hear anymore.
(laughter)
- Fine.
- All right.
This is back into pop.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
I'll just let you know,
this is back into pop.
We're off Broadway
- Okay, okay.
- [Seth] We're back into pop.
- Okay, okay, okay.
♪ I come home, in the
morning light, my moth-- ♪
(buzzer)
(hands slam)
♪ My mother says when you
gonna live your life right ♪
(audience cheers)
- [Kandi] You got this!
♪ Girls just wanna have fun ♪
- [Seth] Very well done!
(bell dings)
- [Kandi] That was terrible!
- We're not doing great, Kandi.
- I'm doing terrible! Like...
- We're not doing great!
(laughs)
- [Seth] She's on top of the world.
Hottest of the hottest girls.
I'll give you a hint.
- [Kelly] Wait.
- This is how you feel in this heat.
- [Kandi] This is not my game!
- Hot.
♪ It's getting hot in here ♪
Is it that song?
- [Seth] No.
- No? Oh.
(audience laughs)
(buzzer)
No.
- I feel like, so slow.
- It's so hot right now.
What is so hot?
What is so hot when you
touch it, you're like, "Ow!"
- [Kelly] A burn. Fire.
- [Kandi] Fire.
- [Seth] Yes.
♪ This girl is on fire ♪
- [Seth] There you go!
(audience cheers)
(bell dings)
- I don't really know that song that well.
I don't, I'm fail...
- [Seth] All right.
- [Seth] Just get your
hands ready, 'cause this is-
- This is turning out to be a crap game.
- This is it, gimme. It's two to one.
Kelly has two, Kandi has one.
This is gimme, I don't like...
Put your hands right on top.
- No, it's not that we...
It's just we don't know it.
(laughter)
- You're gonna, I'm telling
you, you're gonna know this one.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay, okay.
- [Seth] If I can make it
there, I'll make it anywhere.
(audience cheers)
(buzzer)
♪ New York, New York ♪
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Seth] There you go!
You're tied!
(bell dings)
- [Seth] It's two to two.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
I'm going to be honest with you,
might not have gotten that one, either.
(laughs)
I'm going blank.
- [Seth] You can-
♪ Anywhere and it's ♪
- [Seth] Remember, guys-
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [Kandi] Oh!
- [Kelly] Okay.
- (Seth) Remember you can...
You don't have to wait for me to finish.
- I'm trying!
- [Seth] I'm going to do this one slow.
- Okay.
- Feel free to buzz in at
any point if you know it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Rah.
(buzzer)
♪ Rah, rah ♪
(hums)
(audience cheers)
- Oh!
(Kelly hums)
- Bad Romance!
- [Seth] Three to two!
- [Kelly] Bad Romance!
(bells dings)
- [Seth] Three to two!
That means Kelly wins!
(Kelly screams)
(audience cheers)
- [Seth] Congratulations!
(blow horn honks)
- [Kelly] That was-
- [Kandi] I was lost!
- We're so bad at that!
We were so bad at that.
- [Kandi] I was lost.
- Me, too, me, too, me, too.
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh!
You smell amazing!
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] I don't know what your wearing,
but you smell amazing! Okay.